welcome to this video for round two of
them Istanbul olympiad coverage um yeah
we have to run to yesterday and in terms
of match results there have been very
few surprises still mostly am the
matches some who were still very uneven
with one side being the huge favorite
there's only been one very a big upside
down with the Netherlands losing to
Venezuela despite being huge favorites
at least on boards two three and four
they are rated to their opponents by 2
300 points at one point bored I even
nothing but there's the last wonderment
didn't manage to win one when really
even tried for more than 100 moves to
break his opponent down but didn't
manage so this was the only real upset
in fact I'm in the pyramid system some
system even brought up some pairings
which were rather open even in terms of
predicting a result for instance the
German team which is seeded a thing on
9th place or 10th planes around that
like question um my god led the team
from Georgia which is very strong
features some for GM's around 2,600 so
Germany was only about 50 60 points
better at each board they managed to win
to enough but this was rather a close
pairing but all in all they haven't been
so huge upsets in terms of single result
some there has been one one big thing
going on for fun for the Ukraine team
with even shock played his first game
and losing this game which isn't really
good news for Ukraine as even shock is
known to be a very streaky player if he
begins to win games he might even
continue until the end of the tournament
was winning and winning and winning but
it also can
be exactly the other way round alas to
look at Ukraine won the tournament
brilliantly but even shock really was
yeah the side of the engine of this team
and one may be an unlucky word it's not
like he was using an engine but he was
sort of pushing him forward with them I
think he had like an eight and a half
out of ten or something a brilliant
result on yeah in this game which even
shock loss there won't be my main game
because frankly speaking there wasn't
happening so much until the end when he
when he blundered but I want to UM show
this quickly still how it happened so I
go through the move rather quickly
what's a Sicilian with Bishop b5 and the
whole game pretty much looked like white
was intent on playing very solidly and
not risking anything you can see that
the C file has been opened but now we've
got this transformation of the position
where white has the backward see porn
and gothic like I certainly very
comfortable here yes huge pressure on
the sea farm wide can barely hold this
together and I think it's pretty clear
that in this kind of position black
should have some plan to yeah to UM to
make progress and finally win the game
especially considering that he is yeah
by far the better player ukraine was
playing um I think the United Arab
Emirates and I correct on this so this
was sloppy preparation by me another
great Qatar sorry Qataris sorry army and
armor ikea is a pretty good grandmaster
he had been rated 2600 before they lost
a couple of points so it's not an easy
opponent but black has a very
comfortable position here but somehow i
don't know he went a bit astray in the
process and why regrouping the queenside
you see that he's shuffling around a lot
on the queenside
he somehow didn't make such huge
progress and he continued a bit now it
has changed a bit with black getting the
d5 square which is also nice for the
night but also noticed that he has got
this somewhat weird rook on a form this
rook I'm of course makes pressure here
on a tune but it doesn't have a good way
to return like my play b5 at some point
and then return with Luka a 66 but
otherwise this rook is a bit y am
somewhat for summer trapped here on the
queenside and you see the Dwight is not
pushing on the Kings side and he also
doesn't really try to get the rook back
and yeah white breaks open the King side
now and gets a serious counter play as i
mentioned i won't get into this huge
detail but now White has serious counter
play and down he aggressively opened the
kingside this might still be a very good
for black some then unwrapped here but I
really want to show what what happened
at the end because it was an absolutely
unnecessary loss really so takes took
here Queen here and now we play droop c6
and in fact resigned the issue is what
said what's happening now why did you
resign you could could ask I guess
because of Queen a fade and what should
the like play now you got a very simple
threat and also this night is is
attacked in fact them the only thing
that I could do is give a couple of
checks here
and yeah now black ass out of moves
still has those those two issues so we
won shook resigned correctly not even
awaiting this Queen f8 move so I'm a
very unnecessary losses black certainly
it was very good at various stages of
the game and we can only hope that
Yvonne Chaka he recovers from this
because if he's in good shape he's
always um yeah a very interesting player
to watch the place very enterprising
interesting Chesser let's hope he
doesn't get into some sort of yeah
downward spiral here after this son
after this unlucky start of the
tournament okay and the second brief
impression that i want to show from
yesterday is some excuse many to to to
open up this son this game oops sorry so
this is some Levon Aronian first game in
the tournament against them the team
from Bangladesh they even have grandmas
on board one from master Ramon and I
also want to go briefly through this
this Vince masala from rare line
connected with 1d6 and it certainly
looked at live one had a nice position
but then I think all in on like defended
quite well we see here that white has
gained the bishop pair with black having
captured very early on f3 and white has
slightly deteriorated poor information
but okay I've got to get those two
bishops so on why should be quite okay
here so I've continued
and we have now a transformation of the
position worldwide has given up this ms
Bishop but get some pressure on the six
but you always have to keep in mind that
white has flat palms against three on
the Kings side and with this kind of
formation it's very hard to get a
passport so even if white would win the
d6 pawn then it's very likely that at
the end you you get something with four
points against three on one side and it
just a draw so we see that term after
some further moves then in fact exactly
this scenario happens even like God g5
so it's completely symmetrical at this
point the difference is that why this of
course slightly more active you can you
can see that the entered with the Queen
and has got some some nasty position
rook but still it's hard to imagine that
on black should lose this game in fact
might only a say in one trick here if we
go back here slightly you notice that
white is attacking the f7 pond and this
might be something that yeah black
should take care let's say just them
just for argument's sake like what would
play a move like this year it doesn't
have a specific IDM then there's this
nuclear trick and it's check made and
neither a trick you really should yeah
sort of remember because it crops up
rather often so let's let's continue to
the game here black it looks like like
was seeing this idea and preventing it
with 26 Quincy six and now I took so
this is the way le11 is first game
like simply a I don't know overlook this
idea here it seemed like he was
recognizing it but he had just blundered
he had 25 minutes on the clock so it
wasn't like a huge time travel even in
town from the Grand Master should
actually see this instantly so I'm a bit
of a lucky win maybe it's not I think
it's very unlikely that he would have
won otherwise but okay right has a
little something he's more active but
still I would think advise the most
likely likely outcome so get this was
the first winner for aronia nenjam the
minion teen mom yeah manage them for 40
I think yesterday ok m for the main game
I selected a game by Nigel short for two
reasons i like the game and i also like
um hoops yeah very much like short as a
commentator and yeah and as a person he
saw was quite outspoken and it's got
interesting views on various subjects
and it was an interesting game Brazil
was some the opponent of the English
team and ah I see now this is of course
a bit irritating I loaded the game but
it somehow they kept the ratings he have
caught the ratings are not correct
shortest a little bit below 2700 and
diss epona alexander fearsome to 580 or
some things are very strong Grandmaster
um so let's see what what happened short
played one in from this usual move in
recent years he always also experimented
a bit with c4 in default 'if Royce's
main weapon yeah if you placed in
Sicilian and short goes 93 um dia
Nigel's who plays the main lines but he
also experiments a bit with various
sidelines on 193 and a fraud pretty much
fits the bull exam go on pre attack
note that black here on avoids and only
96 we would invite a pin but Bishop b5
so in this configuration yeah right now
has to decide where to put the bishop
and the old and sure if you can call the
old car maybe the traditional called a
continuation in see Bishop c4 but I'm
not so sure but I think this kind of
ideal with Bishop c4 which is sometimes
rather crude to detect the f7 corn I has
fallen a bit out of fashion and focus
nowadays has more shifted to putting the
bishop on e5 so short play Bishop b5 now
96 of course is a possible answer now
but then like always has to reckon with
this kind of construct to change and I'm
not too sure if he welcomes this so in
the game he played that Bishop d7 here
Sean played a form which is interesting
i'm not sure that i saw this before and
it certainly has been played it's not
them logical move or something I'm
another idea that is possible in this
position is to just play Bishop to c4
back so to revert to this plan but the
white argues that the bishop on g7 is
not a brilliantly plays piece this is
maybe a valid point you can certainly
and play this I think it's better than
having the bishop 1c8 in this position
that's very often like it's just more
flexible with a c8 bishop on C aid with
the possibility to may put it on b7 at
some point or sometimes it's just
helpful to have also d6 covered if you
play ecigs at some point and these six
might be weak with the bishop here okay
but then a short played one a form this
way covering this bishop and a fall it's
not it's not them it's not bad in a
positional way as it someone stops be
life in the long run I'm black just
played a six year and now white captured
um yeah he can't he took with the Queen
now 97 of course and also was was
possible not what would have been bad
and I'm 95 very direct play just
intending to to grab the exchange and
this some sort of leads to a slight
coordination of black's pieces you
played Quincy six now I think this is
fine um maybe from my taste would have
been more to just drop the Queen back i
must admit simply i think that because
the Queen controls important square see
if you think of e-cigs 96 but ok this is
this is okay played III now 97 yeah with
the Queen on da q would have been able
to play 96 this is a huge difference but
ok it's not not a problem Queenie to
this is them this is an interesting with
the ideas that you can see it in the
game okay play to the six and now white
can ignore this with a fine this was the
idea of Queenie to putting the Queen
opposite the king so that the flag would
grab the night now it's a check on the
farm and blacks queen gets lost so this
way any tactical fashion white handsome
kept the knight on d5 and black doesn't
have so absolutely great options to to
kick the night back here for me from 25
here went long castling now which now
attacks the night obviously but it's
certainly a somewhat risky move I mean
the Queen side is slightly compromised
already and it's not move that um yeah I
I heard before column eight legs would
have liked to play but okay you can do
it i think it's a little bad fear anyway
at the black players a pretty original
player with them
sometimes unconventional yeah ways of
approaching the position I have played
them quite a number of times on icc and
blitz and frankly speaking very often
didn't understand a thing what he was
doing he is still playing a good in a
way with it some HS I don't really
understand so well let's put it that way
castles um yeah now it is hang on d5 so
93 needs to go back and of course it
goes to e3 and not there to see three
back because this is just more flexible
the night has them potential idea to
drop to see form it might support f5 and
you also have the option sometimes to
play pawn to see form so it's a good
position of the night only three yeah
black play d 5 which is I think fairly
logical castles and now night h6 yeah
looks a bit weird to put it on h6 but i
think it's a it's a good a good to DM
you have you have this idea for instance
and they also watch some slight
technical problem with 96 which is this
kind of normal looking move on Knight f6
son alright could play 25 and for
example on this this kind of move you
have 95 and it's a bit problematic f7 is
hanging g4 threatened it's a bit term a
bit of an unharmonious position so not
h6 is perfectly okay and our wide plate
b5 closing the center I think in this
position one like made a slight mistake
he played now 95 which looks rather
logical admittedly I thinking maybe you
should play f6 immediately breaking up
the center try and for counter play in
the center and maybe even drop the night
here to to put more pressure on only
five I think this is better if you look
at the game all night at five sharp
blade c4 and now I'm
like facing some a slight dilemma here
he am has got this pressure on d5 and I
think he needs to release it somewhat
you cannot really allow why to take on
d5 and what should you do in the game we
play d4 which I think it's a real
mistake and what else could you could
take on c4 but if you look at this
position it might not look so bad at
first sight but if you look at it more
closely you'll see that this term is
really a problem for black the sea
forbes named know this this is a 44
night is just a brilliant piece it has
got all these ideas so black must watch
out for this at the moment these squares
are covered by the Knights but this also
means that you need those nights two
nights to some or restrict one whites
night it's not a good deal and why it
has a very simple plan to improve the
position again just go on Bishop here
look let's say 2 c1 + B form and the
position opens up you might even
consider you should be to you one f2 to
get it on this diagonal and in the
meantime a black simply has nothing you
can just sit in wait you can play f6
maybe but you can just stay there both
nights are covering e5 so I'm very good
position and the pretty colorful one by
now yeah so taking a dinger really help
you play daddy for though I'm not sure
maybe both both them options are and
great but I think before maybe is even
more young more and comfortable for
white now he just went here and now you
see the problem why it will be able to
play before and open up the beam the
beam line and where's blacks play this
is the problem he doesn't have any any
kind of play he tried of course f6 the
only possible source of counterplay
taking the center and getting this
fisherman
play wyd them just push forward with
before and yeah the beef I will be
opened know our way around that like not
took and like Quincy seven attacking
attacking the pawn and yeah it's really
uncomfortable wide now has two good
moves he played be five and the game
which is quite good the alternative was
to take on c5 which also would have been
very advantageous for large like what we
capture you've got this year with
possibilities to go here maybe later
awesomely the the be fun it's a it's
just terrible our black hood could take
you five of course also a possibility
but then you have cut this kind of idea
attacking me six and if black cab with
list you drop back to before and then
the neither sir yeah just a brilliant
piece covering c5 and intending at some
point to play 96 when and still the beef
I'll just terrible so taking on c5 was
also very strong be five versus fine
however the black cap should be 59 and
wide opened up the bee farm and put a
rook them so blacks King is really yeah
that's really am out in the open now
look you one black drop back to c6
getting a piece to to the defense until
white played rugby 6 in fact here I
think he could have played a little bit
more decisively with taking only six
like was allowing this from yeah for the
loss of something something better um I
think this would have firm
let you also rather quick win if you
look at this what should black play
let's say rook g7 you just go here and
what should like do something like this
black is completely tied down to show a
possible continuation let's say h6 take
take and you wanna now you just threaten
this and it's no way to stop this like
just gets gets destroyed yeah it's just
a formidable attack and okay on Queenie
six if black would play Queen to d7 then
there are some more than good one good
line one possibility is just to go here
and get a six you'll you get a pawn and
still have having a tech going it's
maybe a bit of a matter of taste nah
Queenie six was suddenly strong but down
the way that he played in the game which
is root b6 ultra also some huge
advantage um yeah black now played king
d 7 um yeah there were alternatives you
could try to to cover the pawn on e6 in
this way this is what the threat now
after all we'll put Italy winning so a
threat if you ignored but your white can
also just take a six and like it's
pretty much busted the king is simply
cannot stand this kind of position then
the game we played King to d7 and white
now just went 95 the median immediately
threatening made in one with Queenie six
and also this kind of ideas yeah Black
has got only this move to take care
about this and I just took the porn
this is not so much taking a pawn but
also removing a defender of the b5
square so that this kind of idea comes
into play if this night would show up on
b5 then it's really curtains I think so
it's not just a pawn rep black played
rugby eight nine and nine two before
this is of course I ask where your dream
about attacking c5 yeah like now it took
a five and now the mentioned night a
three with this not be five IDM so on
Lex king is really a getting under heavy
fire now nine to be 3 and 9 2 p-5 very
nice yeah grab c1 the new time attacking
the queenside that you cannot take on c7
so just recapture and Queenie five yeah
and in this position white gave his
check and the King Robb back here yeah
short played a very very nice move which
um unfortunately yeah isn't the
technically best one in the position but
it's it's very nice I think I couldn't
have resisted as well I would have
played this no matter what he played na
na g5 and sacrificing the Queen yeah
okay you can read pretty quickly see
that black cannot take it um because I
ok just Queenie to you've got to check
on f7 King to see it and the very nice
rook c7 mate very nice meeting net here
good through the night covering g8 and
those pieces yeah giving the check very
nice very nice and it's just that it
wins doesn't win immediately which
another move from ya would eff yeah he
also could have played that very simple
Queen d2 I think it's just the case
where you see this this night is nice
sacrificing line it's winning yeah it's
winning no no doubt about it it's just
that the simple move Queen d2 would
would have just one absolutely instantly
with Queen 85 coming and this is just
deadly black black cannot do much can
play something like this Queen here King
here and then this system is an itch I
need idea will be semi king cakes and
wide wins the house yeah this would have
been just quicker but what he played
this it's just very very nice it's
nautically very nice and it's winning I
mean I cannot take it has another move
who can cavern f7 but still this is a
completely a winning position for for
white zone cannot really blame short
here for for playing this okay he
exchanged and now rookie won the thing
is some White's attack is still a heart
is strong in this position even with
Queens down black has completely
disorganized pieces and and all once a
week so black will loose material
shortly and it's it's still a huge
attack it's not like sometimes a common
mistake very often Magus you have a huge
attack and then at some point you can
drag material and you cannot resist to
grab material like one power nap two
pawns I bet it's still not so clear
maybe positionally but you wanted to
grab the material and then you notice
okay the attack is over you have some
extra material and you then for whatever
we had reason you cannot win the endgame
so when in this position after the Queen
exchange white also has a huge attack
going it's not like he his or anything
so rookie one that's attacking the the
bishop on e5 like move this and now why
took on them e cigs yeah like 110
King to c8 it's pretty amazing that
there's no direct meet here at least I
don't think there is Marco Luque form
very strong and black gum gave this
check the first first kind of reaction
in this position of courses hey right
white can take it right so take here
like we captures and then you've got
this very beautiful checkmate the
problem is though Black has this this
kind of thick this kind of trick and
it's no checkmate anymore I think this
is still winning if you look at this
this is dylan and game which is
completely winning for white but it's
not better than more what he played he
didn't took took the bishop he just
played king f1 and this simply a threat
threat dismayed again of course this
man-made also so black and valium keep
this together here white took one c5 and
this is perfectly okay in fact he was a
scene here if you look at this with the
computer the computer is telling you
roop c7 is some mate in 50 moves or
something but then it simply and simply
doesn't matter what the computer is
saying you need to find a solution here
which is simple and and which is winning
and this mover certainly does you take
the importance you five porn and then if
you look at this position it's just a
disaster these pieces are completely
australia the sea porn marches on end
you've got the rookie on the seventh
time pinning the king down to the
eighth-ranked so it's a it's a complete
one looking the aid grab the porn now
this is a quite funny move why would
black can
get the nightie I mean it's completely
lost anyway but it seems kind of funny
to put the light on h2 weather certainly
lost so yeah let's see the final couple
of moves of the game it's a really easy
technical task now yeah 96 and now White
has a very simple mating idea pawn up to
c 6 and then loop t7 mate and we see
this in the game yeah now what also just
wants to get this stranded night damn
the last kind of joke lab like him so if
white now it's um a little bit too hasty
and takes here then it's stalemate like
doesn't have a move Brenda of course
short just played this check and can
capture next move so King here and
you're just to look up and you don't
need to be an X 1 championship finalist
who'd win this so a pretty nice victory
here for short and I think this was the
only woman in the match against Brazil
so he won an important game there to put
down put England to 24 points after two
rounds alright i hope you enjoyed her
these two little game fragments and the
main game for the second round and the
other thing we can look forward to two
interesting matches today and i'll do
another new video on round three I'm
tomorrow morning I guess just like today
yeah thanks for watching